I'm sitting here in New York with Jack
Rose and he's the chairman of the
American Jewish Congress and he's just
coming back from Israel where he met
with Prime Minister Netanyahu check
thank you very much for taking time to
talk to Deutsche Welle pleased to be
here how is the Jewish community feeling
about United States which is run by a
president Donald Trump well I I think
this great deal of uncertainty it was a
very divisive and and difficult campaign
that Donald Trump ran and so there's
some uncertainty on some
unpredictability and you know I I think
they expressed that concern at times
that sounds like a pretty relaxed
attitude I just attended a news
conference in Washington where
supporters of the old ride movement
first praised Donald Trump and then did
the Nazi salute does this scare you and
is Donald Trump in in one or the other
way responsible for groups like that
well I'm not surprised that there are
groups like that we've always had some
some you know alt-right movements we've
had you know individuals who you know
done the Nazi salute so that doesn't
surprise me that they're there I think
what what's concerning is the fact that
too many of these white nationalist
groups anti-semitic groups all seem to
feel you know empowered to come out and
speak so publicly and hold public
sessions and meetings and getting such
headlines but the fact that they exists
is not a surprise why do they feel
empowered III think that the the
divisive nastanovich remarks about
Muslims and Mexicans
gave some on the far right the opinion
that you know that he was going to take
you know some very strong positions
against minorities I I think it opened
the door to them believing that that
maybe there was somebody here who would
you know give them some voice in in
America the the kind of voice that they
hadn't had here for a very long time so
so I think that's an unfortunate outcome
what did Prime Minister Netanyahu say
about Donald Trump did you talk about
him look all Israelis are excited some
of them are you know almost it's
hysteria that what kind of support they
expect from from Donald Trump I think
Bibi Netanyahu and others that were
practical they they understand that you
know American policies still take into
account you know the region the problems
in the region in global front you know
problems and so they they they
understand that there'll be some
balancing here what are they so excited
about Donald trum what do they expect
him to do some of them you know believe
that a president Trump will move the
embassy to Jerusalem take stronger
action against Iran but that's not
Universal I think some of the leaders I
spoke to there you know understand that
that may not happen overnight the
president Trump is you know got to you
know think through the policies and the
repercussions on a lot of these issues
and that what he said in the campaign
may not come to fruition that quickly
yeah yes so so there's a there are
different views in Israel mrs. Rosen
thank you very much thank you